when he looked East he saw the past old
tired dead but when he looked West
he saw the future
gold in the ground
gold in the fields and no dragons in the
sky but his he and his sisters rhaenys
and visenya flew over the great
continent ostensibly visitors to a
Strange Land but when aegon returned he
ordered construction of a massive table
carved in the shape of Westeros with all
the notable rivers and mountains that
they had seen
personal map of the Seven Kingdoms then
ruled by seven squabbling families
[Music]
house durandin held the stormlands from
their seated Storm's end due south of
Dragonstone
house horror of the iron Islands had
also conquered and Enslaved the
riverlands and ruled them from
harrenheal a monstrous Castle Rising on
the shore of the God's eye hey guys
house of the Dragon is based on George R
Martin's book Fire and Blood and now you
can listen to it for free with a notable
trial using a link which you can find in
the description of this video all you
have to do is go to the description
click the link sign up for a free
audible trial and choose Fire and Blood
audiobook go and listen to a complete
Targaryen history including the current
and future events of House of the Dragon
for free
how Stark held the Frozen Wasteland of
the north the oldest largest and
emptiest of the kingdoms has Lannister
held the westerlands the wealthiest
Kingdom thanks to their gold mines
house Gardener held the reach the second
wealthiest Kingdom thanks to their crops
house Aaron held the veil or rather the
veil held them the mountains were
impossible except through the bloody
gate which in
house Martell held the deserts of Doom
probably because no one else wanted them
together the Seven Kingdoms made
Westeros a realm that wasn't yet around
ruled by great families who didn't know
what greatness was
aegon would teach them
though house Darren entitled themselves
storm Kings they were little more than
ghosts their Kingdom in the stormlands
had been daughtering to its end for the
past few centuries helped Along by other
houses most of all by house horror who
were nearly finished with the Monstrous
castle at Harren Hall
[Music]
costly a seat to rule only the
riverlands king argalak knew where the
ironborn would soon turn
you'd think a king who wanted to keep
his crown would be wary of a man with
fire-breathing monsters but King argalak
daranden wasn't called The Arrogant for
nothing determined to arrest his
family's decline he sent an Envoy to
Dragonstone to enlist aegon Targaryen
and his dragons against his enemies
in exchange agilek offered lands he
didn't have and a wife aegon didn't need
for as the valerians did aegon had
weighed his elder sister vizenia then as
the valerians didn't he took the younger
rainies as well
sisters two wives perhaps that's why he
was so Keen to get off drakkenstone
aegon countered argalak with courtesy he
sent his own Envoy requesting that
princess darinden's hand be given
instead to aegon's closest friend Andrew
of brother Orris Baratheon
arghalag answered with a box and a note
these are the only hands your bust shall
have of me inside the Box were the hands
of aegon's envoy how long had aegon been
waiting for such a pretext as his army
prepared to sail Ravens flew to every
great lord of the Seven Kingdoms all
bore the same message from this day
forth there would be but one king in
Westeros those who bent the knee to
aegon of House Targaryen would keep
their lands and titles those who took up
arms against him would be thrown down
humbled and destroyed
poor old argalak he couldn't even match
aegon in arrogance
aegon landed at the mouth of the
Blackwater River and raised A Primitive
aegon fort in the disputed land between
herons and argalak's Kingdom so that
neither could decide whose problem he
was
adopting the customs of the Seven
Kingdoms aegon unfurled his own Banner
with the red three-headed dragon
breathing fire upon a black field
vicenia crowned him with a ruby-studded
circlet of valerian steel while rain has
hailed him as the first High King the
continent had seen since the dawn age
as his Lords and the gathered locals
teared him aegon named his loyal friend
to a small Council led by Oris Baratheon
whom he called my strong right hand the
title stuck and a bus became the first
hand of the king
but for now aegon's Kingdom contained
only a Rocky island and a handful of
fields the other kings at large armies
ships castles and thousands of years of
rule but aegon had
he had chosen for the words of his house
fire and blood
before he was done the rivers fields and
skies would turn red
Aaron of house or inherited a kingdom
that stretched from the iron Islands to
Detroit
too great a kingdom to rule from a
castle a shittiest Spike for 40 years
his ironborn plundered the riverlands
for stone Timber and slaves to build the
seed worthy of him
Legend has it that Masons laid the final
Stone in aeronaut on the very day that
aegon landed in Westeros could have been
a Divine Owen
could have been the Masons wants to [ __ ]
off before the dragons got there
they weren't the only ones
at aegon's approach parents river Lords
revolted led by house Charlie
I thought Heron noticed
harrenhal could repel an army of a
million men no ladder could summon its
walls and no Ram could shatter them the
castle was as impregnable as an old
mate's [ __ ]
Aaron shut his Gates around himself his
sons and his ironborn
waited for aegon's Army to drain back
into the muck when aegon finally saw the
Monstrous Castle he asked for Pali
Herron granted it
Valeria had been the greatest Empire of
the world had ever seen
Aaron wanted to piss on its ashes
yield now and you may remain as lord of
the iron Islands
yield now and your sons will live to
rule after you
you see my Army outside your walls you
see my dragons
what is outside my walls is of no
concern those walls are strong and thick
dragons fly
but Stone doesn't burn
when the sun sets your line shall end
Aaron spat and returned to his castle
once inside he promised lands riches and
tallest daughters to whoever could bring
down aegon or his dragon
as the sun sank below the Horizon all of
Heron's men patrolled the battlements
hearing Wings in every gust of wind
but the moon Rose and sank
and no dragon appeared
while the ironborn were ringing the
battlements aegon drove his Dragon
balerion higher and higher in the night
sky so that even the great castle of
harrenhal looked like an ant hill below
them then they plunged straight into the
castle well inside the guarded walls the
five towers of herrenhal reached towards
aegon like a hand
valerion opened his mouth and bathed all
the fingers in flame Aaron was right
Stone doesn't burn but men do
even when their ironborn
[Music]
the dragon blasted my ancestors into Ash
that choked the survivors when they
screamed Aaron's soldiers left for the
battlements and died they huddled
against the walls and died they fled
across the yard and died Aaron and his
sons took shelter inside the castle
Stone didn't burn but as Valerian
blasted it with fire It Blow wide hot
the world's greatest Castle became the
world's greatest oven baking the last of
our Sora within it
outside the castle walls the towers of
harrenhal glowed red against the night
and began to twist and melt like five
huge candles with liquid Stone trickling
down their sides like Wax
the next morning aegon forged a new
riverlands
he named The Rebel Edmund Tully as his
Lord Paramount of the Trident and had
the other riverlord swear him fealty as
their new liege for centuries house
horror had terrorized the riverlands
under house Tully the riverlands would
at last return to peace and prosperity
after the castle cooled enough to allow
men inside aegon ventured into the
ruined he'd made of harrenhal
he saw the Ashen bodies The Scorch Stone
and the mangled and melted swords of his
former enemies to his men's confusion he
ordered these useless swords collected
and sent to his aegon fort
while aegon marched on harrenhall after
his coronation auris Baratheon had taken
most of his forces and his Queen rhaenis
with her Dragon South to deal with the
excuse for The Invasion aguilak the
Arrogant King of the stormlands aguilak
had his seat at Storm's end a castle
considered the most impregnable in
Westeros after harrenhall argilac may
have been arrogant but he wasn't stupid
or a coward his Lords advised him to
shut his Gates and wait out the siege
but he'd heard what had happened at
harrenhall and refused to die a suckling
pig cooked in his own castle
he would meet Victory or defeat the same
way with sword in hand
he called his banners and marched to
meet auras Baratheon in the field
thanks to rainer's Dragon miraxes ori's
new argilac was coming how many many had
and how fast he marched so auras simply
seized The High Ground and dug in on the
Hills to wait for argalak
as the two armies approached the wind
rose to meet them and the rain poured
from the sky a gale which would give the
battle its name the last storm
King argilac's Lords urged him to wait
for the weather to die down
that a storm king saw that the rain was
blowing into the faces of the Baratheon
men on their Hills
and argyleck outnumbered the Baratheon
host two to one
with four times as many Knights and
heavy horse
attacked three times argilac LED his
Knights against the Baratheon line but
the hills were Steep and the rain had
beat the Earth to Mud the war horse is
founded and slipped and the charges
collapsed the battle seemed lost until
argilac ordered his spearmen up the hill
blinded by the rain the baratheons
didn't see them until it was too late
one Hill fell then another and another
until only one remained in the Baratheon
Center
if aguilak could break through there he
could split the invading Army and flank
both halves
aguilak and his men charged and the
Baratheon line broke
revealing Queen rhaenis and maraxis
Vanguard burst into flame and his men
panicked the victory charge fell into
chaos and argue like himself was thrown
from his horse
that he didn't yield when Aureus
Baratheon arrived he found the Old King
holding off half a dozen men another
half dozen dead at his feet
or is dismounted to meet the king on
equal footing and offered argilac one
final chance to yield
argilac cursed him instead as the storm
raged around them the grizzled old
Warrior and the bearded upstart fought
for life and Kingdom in the end
aguilak got his wish
he died sword in hand
as word of argylex death spread his
Lords and knights threw down their
swords and fled
Oris and his Vanguard Road to Storm's
end to claim argilac's castle for aegon
only to find the gates barred and the
walls manned
argilac's daughter had assumed his crown
and the new storm Queen was as fond of
yielding as her father
she declared that auras would win only
bones blood and Ashes here
but her man were weaker than her and
that night Oris found argilac's daughter
delivered gagged Chained and naked to
his camp
aguilak had refused to give auras her
hand now or as could have any part of
her he wished
but auris Unchained the girl wrapped his
cloak around her and poured her a glass
of wine
he told her he would take the arms
banner and words of house Darrington to
honor her father's courage in the last
storm
conveniently Orris had none of his own
to discard first the crowned Stang
became the Sigil of hars Baratheon and
storms and their seat
argyle's daughter would even remain in
her home though as a lady instead of a
princess
the stormlands were now aegons
and as tribute aegon demanded the swords
of the men orus had defeated
for what purpose Iris didn't know
aegon now ruled two of the Seven
Kingdoms but he would no longer be able
to take the rest piece meal for the
first time in thousands of years the
Kings put aside their squabbles and
joined forces against a common enemy my
ancestor King Lauren of House Lannister
was head of the wealthiest family in the
Seven Kingdoms when King Lauren joined
his forces to Moon of house Gardener
King of the reach they had the mightiest
Army in history
a so-called Iron Fist to break the
would-be Conqueror but while an iron
fist can smash a man's face in battle
you'd look silly hunting birds or beasts
with it
and aegon had a creature that was both
the Kings had never even seen a dragon
let alone fought one they had fooled
each other for thousands of years and
victory always went to the larger Army
surely a force five times that of aegons
could manage one dragon
but aegon arrived with three
still the Lannisters and gardeners hoped
for victory the battlefield they chose
was a wide plane with firm ground and
clear skies Perth varages and mounted
cavalry
but neither of the Kings spread a
thought for why the ground was firm
there had been no rain for Fortnight
which meant all the wheat and grass on
it were bone dry
perfect for dragons
first the Kings looked like they would
emerge Victorious when the horn blew for
battle their armies swept around aegon's
flanks and there are iron fists of
mounted Knights smashed through his
center before the dragons could even
enter The Fray
but then aegon and his sisters took
flight and Unleashed their dragons not
on the soldiers but on the dry fields
all around them the Iron Fists unclansed
and became a hand out from us
as aegon promised he had none
more than 4 000 men died in the fires
another thousand escaping them tens of
thousands returned homeless monsters
burned and scarred beyond recognition
house Gardener never returned at all
Field of Fire as the singers call it
claimed the last of the garden line and
house Tyrell Rose in their stead as
Lords of the reach and wardens of the
South
as for my illustrious ancestor when King
Lawrence saw the battle was lost he rode
through a wall of flame and smoke to
safety or at least to a heroic capture a
day later where he laid his sword before
aegon and knelt
aegon true to his words spared him and
confirmed House Lannister as Lords of
casterly rock and wardens of the West
why wouldn't he A Lannister Always Pays
his debts and now we owed Our Lives to
the crown that was worth centuries of
subservience at least
besides aegon had a fetish for
collecting Swords not heads he added
Lawrence to the pile as men had
retrieved from the Field of Fire and
sent them back to the aegon fort
with most of the south in aegon's hands
the best chance to throw back the
Conqueror now lay with the north if we
cared enough to try
unlike our Southern Rivals the Stark
Kings of winter didn't Forge the north
into one Kingdom for Glory or gold there
is little of either here but to survive
alone in Westeros the north remembered
when worse than dragons lay waste to
armies
thousands of years ago the sun set on
the Realms of men and the long night
began
a new race emerged from the ice and snow
the white walkers they demanded no Crown
offered no terms spared no life and the
dead marched with them with Humanity
facing extinction as Stark sought out
the children of the forest the most
ancient beings in Westeros and convinced
them to Ally with the men they'd once
fought
together the two races pushed the
Walkers back into the land of always
winter and sealed it off from the Seven
Kingdoms with the wall 300 miles of ice
stone and Earth rising nearly 700 feet
tall
to guard it they established the Night's
Watch a Brotherhood sworn to defend the
living from the dead whose vows are
raised both titles and crimes
after the long night the north tried to
forget it belonged to a continent
perhaps through Pride perhaps through
sheer ignorance you never can tell with
the North
but as news of aegon's dragons spread
Torin star the king of winter knew he
couldn't forget Westeros any longer and
summoned his Lords to Winterfell
many fools Shrugged off the threat while
the rest placed wages on how long the
South would take to burn
silenced them with a command to assemble
their armies and descend from the North
in force as the kings of The Rock and
the reach burned on the field of fire
the greatest Northern Force since the
long night crossed the neck into the
riverlands
when King torrent arrived at the Trident
he saw on the opposing Riverbank the
combined strength of all aegon's
conquered kingdoms
the force larger than tauren's own by
half
and with three dragons
that night King tauren called the
conference of all his Lords and advisers
some wanted to fight and Trust Northern
Valor to carry the day
burn on the Triton
the wisest of them wanted to withdraw to
mope Kalin The Fortress which had thrown
back every Southern Invasion and burn
there
one suicidal Lord even wanted to Ambush
aegon's camp in the dark and kill the
dragons as they slept or at the very
least their Riders it's hard to tell
what would have been his fate burning
beheading
dismemberment
perhaps all three
my ancestor listened to their counsel
and in the morning cross the Trident
under a flag of parlay then King tauren
of house Stark laid his ancient Crown at
aegon's feet and was named Lord of
Winterfell and Warden of the North
and the king who knelt
he had no choice and thanks to him our
soldiers returned to their homes whole
and unharmed
the swords that aegon took from them
were not Twisted burnt or mangled
yet
the veil of Aaron was the last of the
great kingdoms left old and proud house
Aaron did what they always did in times
of strife they shut the bloody gate
sealing off the veil then the queen
regioned Shara of house Aaron retreated
with her son the boy King runnel into
the Eerie their family's impregnable
Fortress
from the top of their Mountain they
could look down on Westeros far below
its problems hidden beneath the clouds
but one day Queen Shara entered the
outer Courtyard to find a young son
sitting on the knee of vicenia Targaryen
and ogling her Dragon Vega beside her
just as he'd asked for another cake at
dinner little King Ronald asked his
mother if he could go flying on the nice
lady's dragon
[Music]
imagined did Vega
remembering her manners Shara asked if
she could have the senior brought some
wine or food she must be tired after
such a long flight but visenia demured
bored with his mother's pleasantries
Ronald demanded an answer poor boy he
didn't even understand the question
Shara hesitated for a moment then asked
for zenya as a mother if it was safe for
the boy for senior shorter it was
what Joys did Shara have
whilst her son circled the castle she
collected his little ringlet her own
Region's Coronet and the ancient Falcon
crown of mountain and Vale which the
Aarons had worn for thousands of years
Ronald had taken to the sky as a king
but he landed as a lordling perhaps he
considered his ancient writer fair trade
for a few minutes of flight as a little
boy would
more likely he didn't even notice the
three crowns at visenya's feet or
recognize the swords of his Garrison
beside them
the heads of Westeros had bowed to aegon
but its heart still beat free
Old Town the center of the faith of the
seven
there dwelt the high septon the father
of the faithful who commanded The
Obedience of all Westeros saved the
Savages of the north and their old gods
when aegon had landed in Westeros the
high septon had locked himself in the
starry sept and fasted for seven days
and seven nights one for each of his
gods
all he received for his trouble was the
Divine wisdom that if Old Town took up
arms against the dragon the city would
burn faithful and faithless alike
after the submission of house Stark
aegon marched towards Old Town stealing
himself for another battle
but he found the gates open
with the high septon welcoming him
the pious fool even had the arrogance to
Grant what aegon had already won and
Anointed The Last Valerian as aegon of
House Targaryen first of his name King
of the Andals and the first men lord of
the Seven Kingdoms and protector of the
realm
as if titles meant anything to a man
before whom time itself now bowed the
maesters would hence divide all history
into before and after Conquest
most expected aegon to stay and make Old
Town his seat
but soon after his coronation aegon
returned to the mouth of the Blackwater
River where he had first set foot on
Westeros
a small town had since sprouted around
his primitive fault
to honor their new master the locals
dubbed it King's Landing
though it looked more fit for a hedge
night with wooden Palisades muddy
streets and piles of mangled swords
carted in from every corner of the
conquest
but when aegon made it his court wood
became Stone black mud was buried
beneath a red keep and the collected
swords of aegon's foes were blasted by
dragon fire and became a seat fit for
the Conqueror and the greatest Dynasty
this world has ever known House
Targaryen my family
my Throne
also it should have been
but while aegon titled himself lord of
the Seven Kingdoms in reality he held
only six the Seventh Dawn had never
knelt
visenya had flown into the veil and
returned with its Crown mimicking her
sister rhaenys had flown over the enemy
Force holding the passes into Dawn and
landed in the castle of its ruling Lady
Princess Maria of house Martell
Maria was 80 years old fat bald and
blind behind her back many sniggered at
her as the yellow toad of dawn
the beautiful renews probably thought as
much when they met she demanded Princess
Mary O'Neil to her brother aegon there
she allowed that um account of Maria's
age and health the simple vow of
submission would do
but the princess told the queen that the
targaryens weren't wanted in Dawn and no
Martel would ever bow Bend or break no
matter how badly they burned
renise could have mounted her Dragon
right then and roasted Maria in the
castle as her brother had done at
harrenhall but whatever she saw in
Mario's eyes scared her right back to
King's Landing with a dragon's tail
between its legs
after aegon's Coronation rhaenys
returned to Dawn with aegon and visenya
and their dragons
but no armies met them in the field and
no Lords defied them in their castles as
the dragons approached Dawn simply
emptied
house Martel had learned from Harren
Hall and the Field of Fire the Dragons
Were unbeatable in battle but wars were
more than battles unopposed aegon
claimed Dawn for his own
but as soon as he returned to King's
Landing his castles were hurled off
towers and his Royal Garrison vanished
in the desert never to be seen again
except perhaps when the winds change and
the Sands cough up old bones and armor
renice returned on their axis intent on
revenging herself against Mary amartel
but Dawn was no longer empty
the dornish kept Maria's promise and
fought even while burning under
dragonflame and they won
one day a bull pierced the eye of
moraxis and knocked the dragon out of
the sky
house Martel remained unbroken unlike
the unfortunate reigners in their wrath
aegon and visenya set flame to every
castle and city but sunspear trying to
turn the people against house Martell
but the dornish stayed loyal and when
aegon returned to King's Landing he
found assassins waiting for him in the
streets of his own Capital if not for
visenya the Conqueror would not have
enjoyed his Conquest for very long
from then on the king and his family
would be guarded by the seven greatest
knights in the realm the King's Guard
when Maria died in her sleep her weak
and tired son sued for peace but old
Maria had exhausted aegon as well and he
granted the request
the Targaryen still wanted Dawn and
eventually they would have it but not at
the point of the sword they would buy it
the same way Greg Lords buy anything
with a daughter as I said for free you
can now listen to the entire audiobook
Fire and Blood On which house of the
Dragon is based and which covers the
entire Targaryen history including
current and future events of House of
the Dragon for free with a notable trial
using our Link in the description
thank you